ready
thank you as chair of this conference
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor's
result of coping 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee of conference on
house bill 25.
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
the legislative staff have the ability
to communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
271-3600
or email hcs at lag.saynh.us
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled i want
to
introduce a staffer in the meeting
assisting us
brad greenland committee researcher
please note that all votes taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote
let's start by taking roll call
all members are here the senate is here
yes
and all the house members are here as
delineated in the notice for
we're here because there were some major
changes made by the senate
their process there were some 25 million
dollars worth of projects
that were taken out of the capital by
to be funded through arpa or
other federal funds it is my
understanding
that all of these were funded at the
fiscal meeting on june 8th
is that correct that's correct okay so
we those are already taken care of so we
don't have to discuss
the future of them and
then you put a similar amount
less forty thousand dollars
back in with projects that the house had
heard about
uh by and large as we were going through
but could not find the funding
there were a couple of things that
um house members have had a question
about
it was all a lot of the smaller projects
from das
and and how they were selected um
if anybody just kind of
brought strokes on we just went on the
priority
the testimony that eas has given us okay
because we had not heard that because we
didn't have anybody to
to do that but there was a
some concern about that and one that we
did not hear about
well two that we did not hear about uh
the bea
the hhs uh
bureau of elderly and adult services for
four million dollars and and i know that
they came in and briefed the senate
because i did
see that um what
so i know it's a match for federal law
yeah so due to one match
um i can't remember exactly
what i heard was it's a 30 year old
ports and harbors uh marine terminal
that was a last-minute ad i believe
what yeah yeah so um one thing
there is if there is a grant proposal um
a great possibility um to
do the work at the marine terminal that
needs to be done
and um we have to provide that match you
can get i think up to 31 million dollars
i've been down there to see that there's
a couple of a couple of issues there one
is that
they're working on a resurfacing of the
dock but the other is that when they did
the new bridge
because the new alignment bridge they
lost
several hundred feet at the northern end
of the
of the terminal and what this will have
to do is to build that back in and
build out a little bit further down on
the southern end of it
and so they'll be able to handle much
harder
and this fits in really well with the
turning basin project being authorized
and with any other future project and
the
returning basin is also a house bill 25
if i remember correctly and you'll see
there's a note there too that says
that if this grant uh is not successful
then that money could be used for other
department of transportation
uh grand matches that are there as well
so thank you
i think mr representative jack you have
a question uh thank you uh
i noticed that this is under the dot
the market street normally you would put
it under pda
but there's a contingency that d.o.t can
use it i assume
that
[Music]
any of the other house members have
questions about the projects being added
i think we're in agreement with the
removal while the removals have already
been funded so
there should not be a question about
those but about the uh
the additions i do have one
and i i think i've shared with you um
our concerns about some oversight on on
some of this
and the first one would be the uh the
rochester courthouse which i know the
governor
had looked at but did not uh fund
because it wasn't the money to to go
forward with that
but right now the senate has added
design money for it but we don't know
where it's going to go
we don't have a site for it and we would
like to put a footnote
into the the uh
the bill that says you can't do the
design until we know uh
where the uh the court will be
actually built so it's sort of like
building a house and have it all
designed and they go look for the lot
so does the senate have a problem with
with
that no and then
and i know the house is not um
and then we also had a footnote that we
were
talking about amongst the house at least
of
saying that two projects um the
rochester courthouse which we're going
to design
and also the the seed money for the
digitization of the supreme court
records
that the intent is to fund those in
future bienniums once the
the initial work is done
does saying intent work
as far as the house and senate are
concerned i i've we've done it before
with with unh
and others that you know if things work
out and we have the money we'll do it
if not um it's still up to the next
legislature to
to decide whether to fund it any
problems with
no problem this is going quickly
and then one other thing that we would
like to add the house would like to add
is a reporting requirement
for all of these tens of billions of
dollars of federal funds that are going
out for capital projects
currently everything that is approved in
house bill 25
has to have a report back to capital
budget overview committee a statutory
committee um
the money that's being um um
approved by fiscal committee uh for
these types of capital projects which
were approved last
there is no report and we'd like to see
that in there just so that the general
court
knows where this money is going and when
mark thank you representative mcconkie
thank you mr chairman
and that would include all the millions
of dollars for the
because they were pulled out yeah we
we can the language should just reflect
no problem with
yeah report yeah okay that
without we had a lot of conversation on
des
huge uh upgrades and we just we just we
just want to see that they tell us where
they are
and make sure we're not you know two
years out or four years out
and we need a lot more money but we
haven't gotten to it that's all it is
but given past issues yes whether
and and as we noticed as we were going
through about 28
of the house version of the capital
budget was for
information technology um we we do have
a concern that
that money is is going out and what it's
being used for
anybody any of the other house the house
is in agreement with what we just talked
about
with those those footnotes and reporting
requirements
the senate is yes um we will work on
getting that amendment drafted
um and ready for signature
um i would remind all the conferees that
it is
next thursday is the sign-off date by
4 p.m since we are the first and only
one meeting today
complete it should be ready for sign off
later today or
latest on monday if you could do it so i
don't have to keep checking
i would appreciate it and for the house
members you can call either
the the republican or democratic office
as need be
and somebody can go down and sign off
for you and the senate has their own
process on that as well i'm sure
ten minutes any any further questions or
comments or things that we should add or
not add or
whatever but i do i do appreciate the
the senate agreeing to the committee
conference so that we could get
those couple things out in the open and
also talk about the reported requirement
that
i think that all of us agree needs to be
done
since it is all of our taxpayers money
well thanks thanks again to you all very
great job thank you john over the center
appreciates the thought from the house
thank you we appreciate you coming thank
you and that completes
this